i have 100 minecraft players here and
whoever builds the best house in one
hour gets a real house this is baloney
server start the game i'm gonna go tell
them whichever one of you builds the
best looking house gets a real
house good luck oh is this a basketball
goal okay he got a driveway
tp to me right this instant the
pineapple oh
if he makes spongebob's house that might
win him a house oh my gosh i think i see
another pineapple over there his skin is
spongebob look at him we noticed you're
building spongebob's house big boy and
if you look over there you'll see
someone else's no way someone can now
build spongebob's house it's kind of
looking like a mango man you better step
it up you viewers are probably wondering
how can you compete in something like
this just hit the subscribe button down
below and we're actually going to give
10 000 to someone who subscribes to the
next week jimmy have you ever seen a
house with chicken legs well i'm judging
based on if it has chicken legs it's
been roughly 15 minutes and look at
everything everyone has built so far
this is going to be hard to judge it's
not supposed to be easy to give away a
house jimmy and our special guest for
this video is tubbo he's in a different
call and he can't hear us what is carl
doing carl's just running on her build
not even helping first he wakes me up
and now he doesn't even assist that's
messed up look at how terrible this
pineapple is it looks like a house from
someone who doesn't want a house oh carl
look at your chicken leg house yeah
jimmy the more and more i look at this
chicken leg house the more i just want
to move right now jimmy it's been my
dream to live in a tree house and look
how cool this one is obviously right now
it looks pretty terrible but i see the
potential he has no mind keep working oh
we should do one of those like like the
little eyebrow windows on the roofs i
don't know what you're talking about the
eyebrow windows double's got some steep
competition to his left a brim house
what bruh meme house i don't see anyone
so like someone just built a brim house
and left yeah how do we never catch them
even if they won i wouldn't be able to
give them their house because they're
not here
if they can complete this i think this
was top three hello
what is up your building is massive what
are you doing i'm trying to make a
skyscraper what are your thoughts on
your competitors houses i'm just
really shaking right now and stressing
if you're better than all these houses
over here you get a house good luck
thanks i don't know if it will
necessarily be good but i like how it
looks so we're gonna go with it judge
stop what you're doing i got a challenge
for you boom i just dropped a stack of
64 tnt and here's a flint and steel you
have one minute to sabotage whoever you
want hey jed you know you don't have to
i mean that's true
but it would be fun though right it
would be funny jedi llama
jedi
oh my god jenna you savage jedi look at
it look at it notice how the house
didn't explode it was a test and you
failed the test badge
sorry all right i'm gonna try out mr
bacon let's see if he has the heart of
gold uh mr baekhyun hey how are you
doing mr bacon i have a challenge for
you here's a stack of 64 tnt and flynn
steel you have one minute to sabotage
whoever you want you don't have to
sabotage anyone but if you want you can
i think i'll play some but i won't light
it off i'll just kind of like sneak it
in the inside here somebody stop this
madman so bacon are you igniting it or
not no well then
congratulations bacon you just passed
the test
and bacon since you were the first
person to not try to screw over another
player i'm giving you a chandler
chandler awesome it's more of a
hindrance mr bacon tubo's house is
starting to look pretty good not gonna
lie oh we still have to do the inside
yeah you get walking on the inside do
the floors do the floors oh my gosh next
house
[Music]
time is up oh
our house is perfect it's too late to
add anything else we gotta go with what
we got we are going to go through and
judge every house starting with this one
and don't forget whichever house gets
the highest score gets a literal house
it's definitely creative i'm gonna give
it a five not the best house i've ever
seen i'm giving it a five as well i'm
gonna go four he is currently in first
place with 14 points because it's the
only house we've judged
okay this one has potential whoa
there's even oh oh look at the name of
the fishes jimmy chandler carl
carl you're the clown fish i'm okay he
said you're a clown what are you gonna
give him after that oh he made a
scarecrow that is cool okay i'm gonna go
seven and a half for the swing i'm gonna
give him a seven and a half as well i'm
giving him an eight he is in first place
with 23 points carl it's time for the
first spongebob house
here we go before i go inside i just
want to point out there's nothing in the
backyard this pineapple is it wow okay
we got the tv the chair but where's gary
why is this all what yeah why are these
stairs so hard to get up this is
affecting my score what is he doing
credit where credit's due he did put a
lot of effort into this creativity-wise
pretty obvious we like cartoons i'm
gonna give him a seven and a half i'm
sorry blue on skye i'm gonna have to
give this a seven i'm going six and a
half well luckily this isn't our only
pineapple maybe one of the other ones
got it right and next is the skyscraper
did he even put anything in it or is it
just hollow it is hollow but hear me out
he got all of this done in the same
amount of time it took this guy to do
that i'm gonna give it a eight i don't
know if i'd live here considering it has
nothing i'll give it a six even though
we had the kid in the call earlier and i
liked him still gonna have to give it a
seven one of those six seven eighters
the next house is floating but it's
missing a roof he didn't even finish mom
came in his room i was like johnny you
gotta go to school i could win a house
mom poor johnny
ten
10. this one's definitely creative 10.
he recreated the up house it's the house
from up 10. the guy that owns this house
is named carl how am i supposed to there
he is get in here how'd he do that oh
that's pretty creative dude i gotta give
this a
eight and a half carl overjudged i
wouldn't say it's a ten it's a ten i'm
gonna have to subtract a point from my
score to counteract carl so i'm gonna
give him a seven
give it a seven and a half i don't think
it's a perfect house 25 and a half
congrats on first place oh pandas out
front bro this is from club penguin this
is the dojo it's karjitsu dojo yeah this
is a nine this is a nine for sure i'll
give him an eight this is the first
place now whoa
up next we have another spongebob house
look he has squidward patrick and
spongebob yeah but to be fair in uh
spongebob they're side by side this is
more diagonal there's nothing in
patrick's house he neglected the
interior
six four all right he lost he can't win
no
all right mr bacon welcome back to the
call hello carl come on come on check
out the upstairs i like the rooms i'm
gonna give it a nine i'd live here
chandler what are you rating it this is
an eight
and a half i'm gonna give it a seven
bacon are you happy with your rating
yeah that sounds pretty good you're not
in first place i'm sorry okay next house
i love you this next house is in a snow
globe i think that's very creative and
then you're in the oh my gosh you're in
a snow club first person to use dogs all
right i'm back from my doctor's
appointment i'm gonna judge the next
house it kind of reminds me of um
sandy's house oh yeah i get that like
the dome
wait a second chandler what happened to
your voice what do you mean you got
dumber
wow
it hurts if you don't forgive me you'll
be on my naughty list
dude this might be my second 10 out of
10. i like it a lot this is very
creative i'm giving it a nine nine he is
currently in first place victory oh
that's cool this guy's claiming victory
before we even give it to him look at
the basement for a secret it says trust
me i'm crewmate
or venting mr b secret tnt story oh nice
the chess a l-o-o that's funny
oh there's shrimp on the ceiling
i'm giving them an eight i'll go eight
and a half nine didn't win that was
close though that's a good one
oh
wait listen to the jingle when you get
closer
he made this oh this is the innater
difference evil
incorporated
i'm gonna be completely honest this is
the most amount of work i've ever seen
somebody put into it i'm thinking i'm
giving it a ten nine well guess what
boys i give it a zero because it already
won dang dude carl i know you're about
to rate the chicken leg yeah but before
you do i'm gonna give it a five so i
can't win
what up tubbo hey it's time for us to
rate your house you want to show us
around tubbo i'll give you the tour so
um it's much more of an outside house
than an inside because the inside's a
little bit cramped and upstairs we've
got like let's not go upstairs
we're back over here we have we have a
lovely little path that goes to a
barbecue area where we're making no
burgers then over here we made a
christmas tree uh coral 10 thank you
carl this is a solid six and a half you
know what since chandler gave you a six
and a half i'll give you a 10 just for
the memes because you still didn't win
whoa
it was good though it was good it just
wasn't the best tub oh you have five
seconds to say whatever you want um
hello
it's over goodbye
so save mr squishy how old are you i am
16. squish i'm just gonna say it you had
the highest rated house and you just won
a brand new house oh my god what is
going through your mind i mean this is
absolutely insane i was in the middle of
class here squishy can you call your
parents i'll be right back hello your
son just won a house for real yeah is
this like a prank no your son literally
just won a house so all those hours have
paid off
oh am i on the television uh youtube i'm
on youtube
oh no video thank god because i don't
have anything on please subscribe to mr
beast
gaming you heard it from stay mr
squishy's mom subscriber we'll see you
in the next video